دائنيست ليبيا اجنيري وساسالك مره اخرى عن
ما الذي نتوقعه عموما من هذا الاجتماع
طالما ان الرئيس الاوكراني يتوقع منه
الكثير وكذلك وزير العدل الاوكراني توقع
ان يتم تحقيق كثير من مطالبهم فما الذي
نتوقعه في هذا الاجتماع الذي تعقدونه
الاهم في هذا السياق هو ان
الوزراء الاوكرانيين هنا وهم يقدمون شهاده
ونحن معا ونحن موحدون وهذا هو الامر
الاكثر اهميه لكي نظهر لي المعتدي بانه لن
يكون هناك ما يغير تفكيرنا فيما يتعلق
بمساعده اوكرانيا من الناحيه الرمزيه
والقانونيه اذا فمذكره التوقيف بحقه
الرئيس بوتين التي اصدرتها المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه قبل بضعه ايام هو امر
رمزي ودبلوماسي
وذلك لضمان ان الخطوه التاليه سوف تتمثل
في تحقيق العداله اذا فهناك رساله مهمه
نريد تمريرها عبر هذا المؤتمر واي مؤتمر
سنقوم بتنظيمه لذلك سوف نناقش القضايا
المتعلقه بتحقيق العداله والسلام الى ربوع
اوروبا
في انتظار ما يصدر عن هذا الاجتماع السؤال
بسيط فقط هل الكل متفق على الذهاب بهذه
الخطوه هل هناك لحمه قويه بين الاوروبيين
في هذا الملف نظرا
لتداعياته التي وصفها
الروس بانها ستكون سلبيه ليس فقط على
اوروبا وانما على القانون الدولي كما قال
مدفي
من المؤكد ان كل المشاركين في هذا المؤتمر
سوف يكون موحدين
دول الاتحاد الاوروبي ممثله هنا كلها كانت
موحده
وحقدنا اجتمعات سابقه من قبل وزراء العدل
وناقشنا قضايا التحقيق العداله وايضا ان
ناتي بمن ارتكبوا جرم الحرب في اوكرانيا
الى المحكمه اذا فكل المشاركين متوحدون
وهم عازمون على دعم عمل المحكمه الجنيه
الدوليه والمدعي العام للمحكمه والفريق
الذي يقوم بالتحقيق في اطار المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه
شكرا جزيلا لك وزيره عدل الجمهوريات
لاتفيا ايناس
ليبيناري كانت معنا من